es ist ein bild das man aus deutschland
so nicht kennt das sich im kühlraum des
kopenhagener zoo bietet fünf grob
abgehobene pferde schenkel hängen am
haken daneben liegt in einer kiste ein
pferdekopf mit einem schild auf dem
steht tasmanische teufel samstag im zoo
in dänemark ist das mittlerweile gang
und gäbe privatbesitzer die ihre pferde
aufgrund von verletzungen oder
altersschwäche töten müssen lassen sie
nicht mehr für 250 bis 520 euro von
einer tier verwertungs fabrik abholen
sondern spenden sie dem zoo vor dem
verzehr wird das fleisch geprüft also
ist es gut für uns und der besitzer ist
glücklich es ist eine win-win-situation
der kopenhagen dazu ist bekannt für
ungewöhnliche futter methoden hier haben
auch schon löwen eine giraffe verspeist
bilder davon gingen um die welt
den tieren wird der ganze kopf als
futter ins gehege gelegt das pferd als
ganzes zu verfüttern ist gut für die
zähne und die verdauung unserer tiere
außerdem kennen sie es so aus der natur
die besucher des zoos sehen das ganze
größtenteils entspannt henry worm
spendete sein pferd anastasia das blind
wurde dem gips kätzin mittel gerne mag
ich hatte ein gutes gefühl denn ich
wusste dass hier und jetzt das ende
meines pferdes ist ich habe zu hause
noch elf pferde und würde es definitiv
wieder tun wenn die zeit gekommen ist
der kopenhagener zoo nahm bei dieser
foltermethode eine vorreiterrolle ein
mittlerweile verfüttern acht weitere
zoos in dänemark pferdefleisch
inzwischen gibt es sogar wartelisten
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren